julia es una ucraniana de madre rusa que
vive en el vive con su marido y sus dos
hijos no quiere dejar el país sigue
trabajando online y se resguarda en el
vestíbulo cada vez que las sirenas
retumban en la noche hieren before now
we aquí en el vip por ahora estamos a
salvo no hay bombas que caigan del cielo
cae
but pero en el resto del país hay
personas que sufren que mueren este es
terrorífico
para juliá lo importante es proteger a
su familia por ello hace un reclamo a
las madres y esposas de los soldados
rusos a
439 mantense
a las mujeres rosas les quiero decir
vengan aquí a kiev a jarkko fin iniciar
llévense a sus hijos y maridos no se
queden calladas sus hijas no se queden
mirando sentadas mientras nos matan con
las sets en watch house de melenas elena
huyó de kiev con su esposo y su hija
pero aún vive en vilo pensando que el
bombardeo arrebate la vida a sus
familiares apenas descansa y vive
pendiente de las noticias lo primero que
hago por las mañanas es que llamo
a todos mis parientes
dónde están si están
vimos si están
si tienen
un sitio para
para estar
lo más difícil es explicarle todo a su
hija de 6 años
y no los enseñamos las noticias claro
porque en las noticias se muestran todas
esas pesadillas toda la gente todas esas
casas que están en ruinas
julia daniluk por ahora se siente segura
pero no sabe hasta cuándo
me preocupa mi hija mi familia y siento
que no tengo cómo proteger los widgets
elena juliá y lina son mujeres que nunca
imaginaron enfrentar una guerra cada una
con su experiencia intenta sobrellevar
con resistencia y estoicismo este cruel
conflicto